a dijon la communauté juive 250 familles
et parfaitement intégrés fondu dans les
148 l'habitant images de cette harmonie
la synagogue que le visiteur non averti
pourrait prendre s'il n'y avait cette
plaque pour une des belles églises de la
capitale de bourgogne et bien c'est ici
que la vieille flamme raciste que l'on
aurait pu croire éteinte est venu jeter
une étincelle de haine dans la boîte aux
lettres du rabbin ce n'est pas un
message de paix qui a été déposée la
veille de noël mais une litanie de
menaces et d'insultés
avec pour signature une croix gammée et
puis le 8 janvier cette inscription
imiter des méthodes nazies
comme s'il s'agissait encore aujourd'hui
de désigner une cible on sait qu'elle
vindicte publique
ce n'est pas un
que cette inscription n'est pas n'est
pas un fait isolé ça inquiète
ça rentre dans le cadre de de toute une
campagne qui se fait
depuis quelques temps a dit jean est
ce qui nous pousse à penser que
ça n'est pas diriger personnellement
c'est ce qui nous inquiète on a été
absolument écoeuré on en avait presque
envie de dégueuler vous voyez parler
vulgairement mais c'est vrai
puis on a eu c'était des frissons
c'était s'était pas normal
l'auteur de l'inscription et des lettres
anonymes il y en a eu quatre ne peut
être pas tout à fait normal lui non plus
un déséquilibré c'est l'opinion la plus
répandue à dijon où pourtant la police
mène une enquête serrée pour couper les
ailes aux corbeaux qui se réclame
d'odessa international une organisation
clandestine d'anciens ss reçu de lettre
le mercredi et le jeudi et
le mort dit j'avais eu droit à une très
longue conversation téléphonique humains
pendant 10 minutes qui m'a parlé m'a
raconté une littérature du style je vis
us les protocoles de sion les prouesses
organisée par les nazis balivernes
provocation ou démence peu importe
l'expérience a montré qu'un rien peut
réveiller la vieille pesanteur raciste
en bourgogne comme ailleurs personne qui
me traitaient de petit juif
et puis à la sortie de l'école en
s'expliquer de la preuve de mon coca ça
s'est passé il ya combien de jours une
semaine
donc après qu'elle ait commencé cette
campagne de lettres anonymes adressées
aux membres de la communauté mon père
m'a mis au courant mais je n'ai pas très
bien compris au début ce que c'était et
toi qu'est ce que tu en penses
je pense que c'est simple c'est pas
juste aux cons mais elle que le racisme
existe commenter ces miss maison existe
depuis qu'on a traité de petit juif est
ce que tu es inquiet est ce que quelque
chose comme à plaisir j'ai décidé de
j'avais aussi avant décidé de faire un
sport de combat mais maintenant je me
mets un peu plus un peu plus durement
pour avoir plus de chance parce que tu
vas la boxe française
[Musique]